I came to this video playing a 15 minute
game against border magical budem
magical okay the Queens gambit I guess
let's see I could get could play the
Catalan for a change sure why not that's
also very respectable opening 96 yeah
this looks weird but actually it is not
so bad like a can take on c4 and the
next the next move and detergents poses
to a very well respected position okay
it's playing rather quickly here what
what is going on after this let's meet
at me if we try to remember its castles
or queen a for I believe Queen a for
Queen f4 looks like it's more reliable
to get the porn back okay night d 5 as
the is the theoretical takes and then a
three I don't know I oh wow not
remembering any of that there's also
Queen B 5 sometimes is this the position
whether is Queen B 5 I think it is
there's this also the moose check a
three I think okay I so Anna now if i
take he can play c3 right for the winner
of a porn hmm yeah okay not much of a
choice okay so he's he's not playing c3
thats that's quite that's quite good
news I didn't really want to sacrifice a
pawn here but it it seemed like he could
have forced that okay I'm if I go nite
c4 here my queen looks a bit bit awkward
like a 6b five or now but it's not
really doing much I think I can do that
I'm vlog Bishop d7 I can just go back to
be three he could play Knight b6 maybe
the sister might be a move it taking
default trying to exchange ok so maybe
really be five him
okay I'm going to go into Castle him and
now is retreatin yeah i thought that i
have worked the one here maybe he's got
queen d phi don t wanna that said could
be a good move I don't really want to
take a beer as strengthening black
structure a bit hmm ok now queen d phi f
is really a really a bit of bit annoying
don't want to trade here my group t125
queen txt 585 this looks very solid for
black
hmm yeah that's not too great actually
yeah I didn't see a big alternative on
e3 that's also Queen d5 ok so as it
happened so often he's playing a
something entirely different quickly ok
I probably need to move out of this
specialty 7 a.m. yeah well this is now
very comfortable just this is just a
kind of a model position for the Catalan
where the bishop on g2 is just so much
stronger than the bishop on d 7 ok he
probably wants to play mc5 and some
stage maybe now I can play e5 my cam
didn't do anything like that if I mean
yes if I can take actually ok this is
important I can take it let's strengthen
the structure a bit
how do I actually make some substantial
progress here nitey 1d three c5 this
would be quite nice but on 91 he maybe
has a five and I don't want that really
I could play before but it's not really
doing much besides weakening the
structure
this controls each five and 85 just an
all-around strengthening move and
repairing 91 still 91-85 okay let's see
what he's doing I mean sometimes your
own problems with finding a planner
solved by the opponent choosing some
strange stuff and then you can react to
that okay this is not particularly
strange I should be eight makes lots of
sense okay i play this now if he goes to
5 i'm not quite sure what I do maybe d5
it should still preserve some sort of
edge but okay he's not going for it 93
but should be five maybe maybe okay but
this didn't really help him in a way oh
this is I completely forgot about to be
honest hmm yeah it's a perfectly logical
way to play well okay it's clear that I
don't really want to trade so II for is
like normal but tonight b5 as a very
annoying against that okay no choice i
cannot trade everything over here
it still should be a comfortable
position for white we're just quickly
yeah but night texaspeyton okay they're
their ideas still with d5 of course and
ok I've got space and this is always
nice ok yeah one night a six it's not
helping me much takes on a six rook c6
this route be tool I better I better
keep all this covered likee form I can
move the bishop now the position is
still not easy i'm due to this strong
night on c5 yeah ok so i play a form do
i do i do that or just maybe see
intending to play be six maybe
yeah now Kenny can play be six but I go
to d3 and still keep keep a very nice
position to see pawn this week just the
transformation of weaknesses I thought I
can just take can I not i'm in d6 hangs
ok if you would if this what what was a
possible move of course then Mike my
only a play wouldn't make any any sort
of sense so c6 now yes I need to let's
keep this
okay so how to play that Bishop aged
three years a good move yeah so that you
don't always have Bishop d7 very sick
every am very reliably on covering the
c6 porn yeah I think a form there are
something no we cannot take okay
my idea was to to give the exchange now
which is kind of a keep it simple
approach almost because the night is
always so annoying but maybe just with
the King King III yeah I can do that you
can play look the 8th here exactly
threatening now to take on these seven
but I thought that were maybe not
actually I thought broken once III would
be good keeping it covered but he's got
might be five after that no way I've got
there should be six check okay
okay a for a for to prevent this and
improve the position further I don't
really see a movie cannot move the night
anywhere and this setup here Bishop on
d7 Brooklyn c3 is completely paralyzing
his rocks yeah so now grabbing now on
deform or how how is the most precise
way to do it
I'd like to do it in a way that it
limits his counter play as as much as
possible i'm thinking maybe here and
take twice with the rook this is
actually quite quite good yeah take
twice with the rook and then put the
rook on d5 this is completely paralyzing
black and then I can invade with the
King um okay let's do that Jack rook t5
and then I'm invading King to be five
that is not defensible I don't think it
is that I don't think it is um go H form
not really it's not helping h4 I can I
can win the slow tempo here on age five
age 3 root gauge for I mean it's not
really a threat but better to prevent
absolutely everything and now King goes
away so let's see he's this is almost a
zoosk lung when I set this up I was
thinking that Bishop f5 or 37 could be
enough but I'm not so sure I should
probably I can pry can gain even more
space here I cannot really do anything
maybe takes rook age 5 or g6 look age
five hmm yeah it's both nice I think it
says this is better that I can actually
enter with the rook yeah we can go to c7
but it's it help if I go f5 actually in
five and then look on the yeah this is
quite strong takes I can go to d5 maybe
Jack Rabbit okay this should should be
okay
check yeah then on check on to the 7th
and this point is also moving take he is
this is easy and now Roxy four and six
seven check
check
yeah it was a bit bit too much already
um just not not not a stalemate after
the capture Bishop takes he can go to
age seven black resigns yeah this was
some still I mean what I what I really
did did barely ahead and just overlook
this Bishop c6 idea which I really
should have considered it wasn't a big
problem but it's um it's a move that you
simply need to consider and have an idea
against I mean this was this was okay it
keeps it keep something for wide I'm
still having this Center and the night
on survived but it wasn't really a
planned operation yeah I mean I'm always
keeping some sort of advantage but here
this is the c5 was was just a yeah this
was just just flat losing and there were
probably even better ways to play but I
like the I like the exchange sacrifice
idea it keeps blacks counterplay to
absolutely zero this was not jesibl I
mean actually was possible now that I
think of it as always thinking about
this but of course I can take it back
this is probably also quite winning I've
gotta control the important squares with
my king and i have this invasion idea
but i think this was more precise just
take every color every possible
counterplay away check and he is no
option anymore to to give the h
back just just like he cannot move
anything check MIT I'm just invading
would have f this two against one in
addition so like warm have no chance to
defend this yeah it really the the
problems really started check i don't
know the theory have it here but should
be some this Queen d5 is what he needs
to do it's pretty clear that this is the
movie should play and it's quite typical
that I didn't see the best reply the
computer points out immediately night a
three which is just just the best move
it looks a bit a bit counterintuitive to
put the night back here on a three on d
on the edge but it's just better than
taking I mean the only other move is
taking and this is now perfectly fine
for black because the pawn on d5 let's
say after this is perfectly blocking
this bishop and this bishop has a role
now on only six black and try to also
regroup the night play C 6 and this type
of cards but structure is no problem at
all with the bishop on g2 zone Black has
an easy quality this means this is the
move that I must play and I doubt that I
would have seen it it looks a bit
strange but once you see it it becomes
obvious that is the best move black can
not take yeah just just terrible I mean
you can defend with 9 a-8 but how does
this look um he probably plays something
like that and then you can retreat the
Queen and actually can try to play
against the Queen on d5 which is also
bit of an a bit in the way of this
bishop so okay this was some
this was an important point 9 a-3 well
the way it went down when when I was
able to to get this tab position it's
very one-sided because this Bishop is
just so much better combined with the
central dominance that black has a hard
time to equalize alright thanks for
watching